between its demanding tactical battles
deep class system and social some
elements fireman three houses can seem a
bit overwhelming if you don't know what
you're doing you and your students could
be at a significant disadvantage here's
some tips that could give you an edge in
Fire Emblem three houses after you pick
your house black eagles for life you'll
be assigned to a group of students but
eventually you'll be able to recruit
students from other houses in order to
recruit someone you'll need to talk to
them and complete a basic skill check if
your bond and skills are high enough
they will agree to join your class I'd
recommend recruiting all the characters
you like as soon as possible because
there's no telling where they might end
up later in the game terrain conditions
can make a huge difference in fire
emblem trees make your ground units
harder to hit but decrease their
movement range standing in fire will
naturally harm characters over time and
sand makes it really hard for your
mounted units to move but there are ways
to use terrain to your advantage some
classes like the bishop are immune to
fire for example while mounted units can
temporarily dismount to better Traverse
and
these items will give you a brief
description of who they belong to and
you must return them when you return a
lost item to a student or faculty member
your bond with that character will
increase and if they're in your class
they will gain a bit of motivation lost
items typically appear where someone was
hanging out the month before so if you
get stuck on one think back to who might
have been in the area if you find a lost
item for someone who already has max
motivation I would consider waiting to
return it until after their motivation
drops
it can be tough building up violets
skills since you can't directly teach
them like you can with your students if
you do need to level up a certain scale
professors scattered around the
monastery can give by lift one-on-one
lessons however I wouldn't worry too
much about baile skills when it comes to
which class you should aim for without
spoiling too much things will fall into
place eventually support levels and
conversations are back and they function
pretty similarly to before as you battle
and bond with your students you will
unlock conversations that rank up
support levels not only will you learn
more about your students but you'll get
a stat bonus when two or more friends
are near each other on the battlefield
so make sure to check the support menu
often
don't forget to manage your units
abilities before battle as a character
levels up in different skills they
unlock abilities that correspond to what
they've learned like better stats when
wielding an axe or higher avoidance when
using magic the abilities have to be
manually equipped so make sure you've
slaughtered in abilities that match the
unit's current class and load out before
you start fighting probably one of the
most important battle tips in this video
is to use Zr to see the range of your
enemies when you press the R you will
see purple outlines around tiles if a
unit is inside one of those purple tiles
that means the enemy is within reach of
your unit you might even want to leave
this on throughout the entire battle
especially if there are Pegasus and
wyvern units on the battlefield
[Music]
if you aren't sure how to spend your
time during a free day in game I
recommend sharing a meal or two with
your students this is a good way to bond
with them increase their motivation and
build up your professor level eventually
you'll unlock a blacksmith in the
marketplace
here you can strengthen and repair your
weapons keep in mind that repairing
weapons will cost you gold and smithing
stones
I wouldn't recommend repairing every
weapon as it can eat through a lot of
resources in gold but there are some
weapons you get later that are worth
repairing
you can also Forge rusted weapons you
find on the battlefield into useable
weapons with some goal and materials
fire inland three houses is a complex
game especially if you're unfamiliar
with the series but once you get the
hang of it it's a deeply satisfying
tactical RPG hopefully these tips helped
and if you have any other tips please
leave them in the comments below thank
you so much for watching
[Music]